the muslims have become very weak the
muslims
don't respect themselves the muslims
don't honor themselves
so here came a man from the mountains of
dagestan who
came in and revived many of these
principles in the life of the muslims
you see he perfected what he does and he
perfected it but it didn't change him
also
one of the teachings of islam the honor
and not being shy
not compromising the the clip that went
you know went around recently about
him not shaking hands we've seen it
several times he doesn't shake hands
and not compromising this is what our
religion teaches us we don't shake hands
with the opposite gender we always made
it clear that his faith came first
ufc 200 which at that time was the
biggest ever you know this was the
biggest event
it was in ramadan he was like no i'm not
taking part in it he's very clear the
reporter said and he had said to him and
whiskey like in the same sentence
and he stopped them and he said don't
don't say those two together you know
i'm saying no it says it's allah you
know
and it's saying alhamdulillah and how
many people around the world now from
the non-muslims
they know the word alhamdulillah
constantly making dua to allah you see
him when he's in the dojo
praying and how many people would reach
that level they would go astray
we sit back now on our couches and we
talk oh man
if you were to recent level of success
and you had that much money and that
much
fitna in front of you you think you
would be devoted you might say it now
but the reality though if you had all
those women
and you say man no no i would i wouldn't
be involved
you know with something like that you
have the women throwing themselves at
you man you can have all the women you
want with that success and that money
and that fame
but yet someone stays devoted to his
wife and fears the law subhanahu watana
is that not to be applauded
[Music]
prayer learning about islam reading
hadith
just things like that this podcast that
would be one right because they're all
you know intertwined two would be diet
three would be training
four would be sleep and five would be
connections
social life keeping you know everything
straight with people
you know roommate if you're married just
these things
but that's just me that's time
management for me yeah subhanallah
that was amazing that's panel that's
life i have to implement
that insha allah yeah
i feel like i feel like god was speaking
through you
because yesterday man like i was uh
making dua
after my prayer and i was just like
allah like just please
give me the ability to just be receptive
and like see what needs to be done
next like give me the the the
ability to be receptive and then the
ability to adapt
and just like start doing these things
you know because it
the big changes are obviously the big
changes and
like bro i'm i'm just shocked
that like you were saying everything it
was just like then you just mentioned
the mma thing that
it all was just lining up perfectly bro
like it's like all these gears in my
head were like
just clicking perfectly bro so jessica
just took a lot of hair bro well yeah
bro i
i appreciate it and here's the thing
quick side note is if you're in a
position to help
anyone don't don't turn it down because
you could be
the answer to that person's prayer
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to the
realist podcast in the game
t3m we are joined with our brother
sheikh abdul raheem mccarthy
salaam alaikum welcome
for the next weekend
what are you doing nowadays just keep
yourself busy
um i i actually have my wife was asking
me have you felt that i said no not at
all i've just been so busy
i have continuous lectures as i'm
sitting with you guys um
it's the middle of night now where we
are um after fajr or a couple hours
after fajr have a lecture in sacramento
and i have some filming i'm doing with
the brothers in the uk in the middle of
the day
you know two lectures on sunday so just
you know preparing lectures and
and talking and doing some recordings um
i'm working out
in a every day alhamdulillah i have my
resistant bands with me which i travel
with all the time as my
form exercise obviously with i can't
really do any burpees and things with my
my knee injury yet so i'm just using
like resistant bands and you know
push-ups and
and things like that i haven't allowed
to you know make sure i get my daily
exercise in
and you know i would speak to my wife a
bit on the phone and
you know answer some emails do a little
business here and there then i found it
that you know
the day's finished something i've been
been very busy and been benefiting from
the time
i think a lot of people you know they
always say that they're bored
when they're in um you know in the
lockdown and
people are struggling in mental health
you know something very beneficial i
benefited from
a new muslim you know muslim sister she
said that one of the things that islam
taught me is that it's impossible for a
muslim to say that they can be bored
and she said because there's always
something to do when islam is a religion
always encourage you to you know to
constantly better yourself right
she said i don't see how muslim could
ever you know she said he could dare to
say that or he could be bored because
you could always be doing something
there's always something to do to better
yourself
and whether it be you know bettering
yourself in your mind educating yourself
and the affairs of the dean and the
dunya and that can take up all of your
time i'm gonna you know with your family
with this
there's always something to do and you
know that you're not gonna you know
have to sit around like i wanna kill
time i wanna waste time i'm bored
there's so much you can be doing that
and when you reach that level in your
life
you need to realize that there's a
there's a problem because there's so
much you could be doing to fill up your
days
and like i told my wife earlier i said i
said what would i be doing differently
if i wasn't in lockdown now let's be
honest
okay i i would go out to the store
sometimes maybe i needed to buy
something
i would have visited some of my brothers
who i haven't seen in some time
uh i went to their house but i'm gonna
how long do i sit with them maybe sit
with them half an hour hour
and then i'm gonna come straight back to
my house and be in my house i would go
out to the masjid
you know other than that i wouldn't be
going up i would be sitting in the house
doing the same thing i'm doing working
that's what i do for a living anyways
i enjoy that's what i do and for me
personally it wasn't really that big
of a deal the issue of the lockdown and
even i don't know if you saw i have a
video that i did about my daily routine
when i was in lockdown you know actually
working out in the morning is is part of
that
and you know i established the home gym
you know something that i had that that
really hit me hard people
i can't go to the gym i don't have a gym
you know even i used to teach my
students when i used to teach them
and uh in dubai actually one of them
became like a
i think it's like a professional
bodybuilder now or he competes at a
professional level
um you know i used to teach them that
everywhere is a gym
and they were like and how is that i
said there's there's so much you can do
right i said right here in school
there's
you can work out everywhere and they
said you know you know what is it so i i
taught them
first of all they were very lazy to take
their um books to their locker so they
had like all of their books for all
like you know 12 subjects or they have
their it's in their bags all their bags
are super heavy
which actually is good you're carrying
around on your back or doing like a
farmer's carry when you're carrying it
from class to class so that's that's
exercise i said also i said look at the
curls you can do with these now
still curling what that is heavy you
know the the the tricep the french press
with the with the bag
um and i said even i said get someone to
hold like a shirt or a sweater or
sweatshirt that they have
and they're pulling it and you can do
different exercises with that as well
um i said take the desk pick up the desk
now this is the teacher teacher
so i'm also teaching these things right
i said the desk is this light they're
like yeah it's easy i said do 20 reps
do do do do do 30 30 of them it starts
to burn like oh this is
that's going to build up their shoulders
after some time uh when the in the
bathroom uh
i was washing my hands when i came and
said look i said that's a pull-up bar
right there
where's that they start doing pull-ups
inside so the
the the teacher was in charge of uh of
the the disciplinary stuff he would say
ah this is a school you know i do that
they'd laugh at me because i'm the one
the teacher who taught them how to do it
you know
obviously in the chairs you can do the
dips in the chairs you have the two
chairs as well
you're not supposed to put your feet on
the other chair but i i'd a lot of if
they're doing dips no problem
so i'm dying you can you know you have
to make the best of the situation that
you're in so
there's nothing i can do i'm locked down
what can i do you're in your country if
you can't you're not you're not out of
the house
what are you going to do you make the
best of what you have with the things we
have online now i mean
imagine this you know before like the
internet
you know that would have been that would
have been challenging right because
there's so much you couldn't have done
but now alhamdulillah and there's so
much we can do online
that i i don't think it's as as big of a
deal as as people make it you know
there's a lot of things you can fill
your time with you know
even some of the beautiful things is now
i mean one of the duality told me he
said
i finally met my children you know i
really know my children now which is
something beautiful
because we didn't get the time to spend
with them before you know they're
they're always busy
they're at school you know they're in
activities they're you know outside with
their friends
and we know we're traveling we're doing
our work we're doing this so maybe we
don't know them
as much as we should but the the
quarantine gave us and
the time to spend time to get closer to
our families if you took advantage of it
in a positive way but unfortunately many
people
it was a negative experience for a lot
of them because they didn't have the
correct mindset going in
and also i think a lot of times you know
having that type of isolation
in general not you know socializing too
much
unless it's something that's there's a
benefit in it that's that's the way i
always look at it i mean i don't really
hang out and socialize
with brothers unless it's something
we're gonna benefit from each other and
either and and dean or dunya would have
be some benefit there you know for us to
just just have a cup of tea where
there's no benefit behind it i i'd
rather have a cup of tea with my wife
and if that's the situation right
but if we're going to benefit you know
there's some brotherhood there's some
bonding
and visiting and we're going to you know
remind each other we're going to learn
something new
you know that's beneficial every now and
then you know just to kind of chill out
and have fun okay no problem
but it can't be you know too much anyway
it shouldn't be that much anyways
subhanallah man uh the introduction
alone you just dropped so many
so much wisdom right there so many gems
uh i want to kind of
you know rewind back he talked about the
new muslimah that was giving us this
wisdom that as muslims we should never
be born
and it reminds me that you yourself
you're not a new muslim per se but you
are a reaper
right i remember briefly uh you
mentioned somewhere that you represented
back in 94.
so tell me a little bit about that your
upbringing what brought you to islam
uh what you kind of did after accepting
islam a little bit of your education in
your background
and where you are today yeah angela um
i'll tell you the one of the briefer
narrations and just like if you look
in sahih bukhari and most of hadith you
find like imam bukhari he mentions the
same hadith with different narrations
sometimes it'll be a short narration
sometimes it'll be the longer hadith
with all of the information because if i
go into too much detail
we're going to take up the entire
episode and i'll say i've talked about
this several times before
but perhaps some of the viewers maybe i
haven't heard the story so yani
like you said i'm no longer a new muslim
because the majority of my life
has been in islam alhamdulillah if you
do the math in the years and when i
became muslim i became muslim i was 18
and i i i've lived more than 18 years
after that
more than half of my life has been in
islam alhamdulillah
more than half of my life has been
overseas in the middle
east or the arab world as well so
alhamdulillah
i have a lot of different experiences
and i was born and raised in
america in the state of virginia
and in 1994 i accepted islam
um i came from a good background you
know
my family was when i was born like an
area it wasn't part of the nicest area
but my family were a bit successful from
from the start we moved into a nicer
area
and eventually started to move up and up
and up until we moved into
very pleasure areas alhamdulillah so my
family were you know very successful and
still alhamdulillah
um you know they're well-off you know
very very good
family they taught me very good values
and
unfortunately uh and unfortunately i can
say i mean i i don't want to complain
because i
i think i've the i benefited from my
jahiliyyah and then you know it came in
the hadith
the the the best of you in islam are the
best of you in jail you know the ones
who
he said either who if you learn the
fifth and you have knowledge of the
religion
because a lot of the the things that we
took from the jahilia we cannot benefit
from islam
for example relating to the youth
relating to the to the shabab
i've done most of the stuff they want to
do or they're doing
i've been through that so i mean for me
to be able to relate to them or for them
to be able to relate to me
you know that that there's a connection
right away so it's not like
you know um we talked before about mma
i remember there was a i was given a
lecture on the university in ireland
and the issue of mma came up and there
was a brother he's a you know very
active endowed
he's the head of the pediatrics
department in the hospital he works that
was a very very
brilliant brother mashallah beautiful
brother he brought this this this
um you know from the youth from his
community he brought him with him
and him you know his imam was like you
know traditional
turban uh you know everything's haram
you know
the cool farthest group like did go back
to your country or something like this
because you're living in a different
world than we're living in right
but anyways everything was haram for the
guys so all of a sudden he's hearing me
talk about mma
and training and stuff like this he's
like this is halal and i was like i was
like yeah
we train that's what we do you know we
train all almost every day alhamdulillah
so he was um he was uh he was
he was shocked to hear that but and so
but he was able to relate right away
because now
and someone who's living like in the
real world you know not not in a bubble
alhamdulillah
so basically any uh you know
when it when it comes to um you know
this this jay helia i benefited a lot
from it that's the point i want to point
out you know that
alhamdulillah you know a lot of the
things that i did there is
some form of regret i'm not happy or
proud of a lot of the bad things that i
did
but i think it has made me a better
person today and it's made me more
thankful for islam
um even my parents i've talked to i'm
more thankful for them what they did for
me now because
of the bad stuff i went through in the
past and what islam taught me you know
it really really helped me out a lot so
i went through a very
very deep uh and rough jahili
you know i found myself because i was
you know really into basketball as i
mentioned
you guys any uh in the other episode
and when you play basketball obviously
you know that the
inner you know if you want to get into
the good pickup games you're
gonna be like in inner city areas right
obviously most people live in the inner
city areas or from
the african americans so a lot of my
friends a lot of my colleagues at school
and the ones i would hang out with they
were from you know the african-americans
and you know i was influenced by them a
lot
and basically became like i was one of
them even
at the time that people didn't know the
difference you know they would hear how
i talked and
walked and act and dressed and all that
and just like i was you know
from that i wouldn't call it really the
hip hop was more like if
the gangster style that more than the
hip-hop you know we weren't into the
you know we had a different style in in
virginia this area where we were from
anyways
the the point is that um my family was
shocked obviously in the things i was
doing
things i got involved if and we didn't
have like gangs
per se i mean there are there now
obviously more uh
the gangs that came into the area um but
during my time there weren't really any
gangs it was more like you know clicks
or crews
of people there were you know some um
but the gang lifestyle was the same
thing basically you know you're into the
if you're into drug dealing and you know
what you would call like gang banging
type things in this neighborhood in that
neighborhood
it's more or less the same thing without
the affiliation so that's
the kind of lifestyle that i got
involved in i was getting into a lot of
trouble
um you know got locked up several times
and it got out
but you know this was just it was a
continuing of course until
one day you know and and this is the
thing
and i even mentioned this we're talking
about you know khabib earlier and he was
supposed to be talking about him and now
as well but
and then one of the things i mentioned
that you asked about that i did in 2018
one of the first principles that i
mentioned was don't judge a book by its
cover
because right away mma fighter hitting
face haram the guy is no good
you know you just cross him out right
so the same thing i i was and i gave a
lecture last night in arabic actually
about that when i was explaining who i
was and what i was what i was doing
the way i looked the way i talk the
things i did really really bad things
you know even i remember my my sister
telling me
that she said you're a minister society
that made me very proud back then by the
way and i was like yeah it's because i
reached now where she called me a
minister to society about that right
so i was like wow i see that that's you
know that's deep so that's how
how my my family looked at me that's
what i had become
but um don't always judge a book by its
cover because many of the people have
been guided
you know alhamdulillah and they went
through a difficult time but now they
become good muslims
our brother now he's got his he's got
his ink right so a lot a lot of the you
know the old uncles
this guy you know he was a muslim
is going to help us now in islam and his
experience that he gained to be able to
help the youth to bring him back things
like that we can we can benefit he can
relate to them
whereas maybe the traditional imam from
back home or something like this
and he uh they're not going to be able
to relate to the youth that's why so
many of the youth
unfortunately go astray is that the the
imams and the leaders that we have in
the ms and the
masjids and the communities that they
can't relate to them you know
they're on different planets all
together that's one of the the main
problems that we're facing
even many of the parents who they still
have the back home mentality
not realizing that your son your
daughter they've been born and raised in
canada and america in the uk
they don't think like you do they don't
think like back home they think like
here that's how they think
but they just can't relate to them and
that's where a lot of the problems are
being caused
so alhamdulillah even though i was in
this situation one of the
you know my partners in crime his father
was a muslim and i learned
you know the basis of islam through him
i asked him for some books
in it i'm not reading those books i got
into a car accident
was chased by the police they didn't
catch me alhamdulillah
i didn't have my car to go out then and
now remember these books that i got two
months ago
from for my my my friend's father
and i sat down and that's one of the
things i always tell my students that
even though we were into like
the gangster lifestyle and you know
crime and all of this
the difference i said we used to read
even back then you know and it was it
was looking at something
positive to read i mean obviously a lot
of times when you go to prison that's
when you're supposed to read certain
things but even when you're outside for
example you have
the art of war you know the prince by
machiavelli you know these are these are
must reads even when you're outside
right
so i i used to i used to read certain
things so i mean
and it wasn't like i couldn't read it
even sometimes i hear some people try to
read today like uh
you know it's like people are literally
they can't even read subhanallah today
um so i mean i had these books i read it
it really interested me i read it cover
the cover
and i had been influenced before by the
story of malcolm x i read the entire
book
i saw the movie you know so they just
that and that that
planet something in me the story of
malcolm x and then boom when i read the
book that
it just kicked in and this is what i was
the direction i wanted to go i made
you know um some goals for myself i was
a young man
and i went to get my money right with
the issue with the women the car the
house you know those
there was a main the main objectives you
know and then i felt i was getting out
of shape you know the lifestyle i was
living
a lot of drinking a lot of smoking weed
and things like that wasn't you know
i i felt that uh you know
the situation i was in i remember we got
into a fight uh with some mexican guys
me and my friend
and the police rode in as we were
fighting and you know so
i was running away and you know back in
the day we were younger we'd run from
the police
and you know we'd come to the fence and
they couldn't catch us there's no way
they're gonna catch us
that was fast i was athletic man we'd
hit those big fences just like
hit into the middle of our slip over and
just keep going like it wasn't even
there
so i remember i was running you know and
i know i was in the bad crowd you know
they're
smoking cigarettes smoking weed drinking
you know i get to the fence that we just
like like sail over like like a gazale
like a deer or something
flying over the fence i got to defensive
that was just
collapsed you know i was like that's not
good so you know i realized when i was
young and you had to use your mind
i was like i gotta get back in shape man
i can't i can't be like this so i mean
that's one of the goals i put the last
thing i put on my goals was
you know to be more religious you know i
felt and that's that's the pitra inside
you have that natural inclination
that you need that connection with your
creator i tried several times with the
bible with this you know being a
christian
i was catholic you know that's how i was
raised irish-american
um you know that's what i believed in
and that's why i tried you know i had my
little gold cross on my board chain
uh you know trying to be more religious
but my idea of religion was more like
you know the guys in the mafia
who would you know do their things
throughout the week and go to church
maybe give them
you know the church on the sunday have a
relationship with the priest you know
yeah that was about it right that's
that's what i that's what i that's what
i thought
i would i would do it may read the bible
and you know and just be a
bit of a better person and i didn't
think that would you know be someone
who'd
be totally religious so many but
obviously you know
as allah told us
they plan in law plans the law is the
best of planners and the law had better
plans for me alhamdulillah
so that day i was going and as we say to
re-up to buy some
drugs from my friend i used to get my
supply from
that i would sell his neighborhood come
back to my neighborhood
but he wasn't there for the appointment
subhanallah so him not being there
um opened the opportunity for me to
speak with his father about islam
and like i said after that i had any i
had the books and then
another plan that allah had for me i got
into the car accident so here in front
of me i have the books that i read and i
read the entire book that night
and i'm that accepted islam the next day
alhamdulillah and allah blessed me with
some beautiful brothers around me
i fell in love with the quran reading
the quran every day
fell in love with the sunnah trying to
act upon it you know i always had the
beard even before
you know i had the the usually have the
short beard back in the day but
um i never really i never used to like
to shave it was it
it was horrible to see a [ __ ] you know a
clean shaven man never
never liked that even before islam so
you know the dress i used to wear the
turban all of this anything that was
sunnah i had my swag with me all the
time you know
walking around in america you know
trying to implement the sunnah of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam in
all aspects of my life and i fell in
love with knowledge and seeking
knowledge
and i realized that if i'm really going
to obtain true knowledge i have to
you know go outside it's common sense
you can see the ones
who are the scholars the ones who had
studied the ones who went abroad the
ones who had the patience
to finish the programs abroad so i went
outside and alhamdulillah
went to sudan started there and then
later in saudi arabia for
about a year in saudi and then i got
accepted in medina
and i stayed in medina alhamdulillah for
10 years in medina until i finished
and then i started my you know my career
as a teacher
as you know someone who's involved in
media many tv shows more than 900 tv
shows that i'm doing on peace tv huda tv
and many other tv channels around the
world and now i'm
trying to do what i can on on social
media and also as an international
lecturer traveling around the world
obviously with covet
it's the first time i've traveled that's
why so i've been locked down now
we haven't we've stopped traveling but
i'm one of the objectives i had even
before
was to do more things online and to
start traveling less so actually
it turned out to be good for me
alhamdulillah so this is this is an in
brief
you know how it all happened
alhamdulillah and where i am now
i can agree 100 110 percent that kovid
was
in a way allah's answer to all of my dua
but you don't you don't really see it
that way you know when you're just too
caught up in it
like angela says um and i really wanted
to touch on you know
the the thing with khabib when when you
know you hear this thing about mma
a lot of people don't know i want i want
you to tell us about why there's this
huge
preconceived notion with khabib before
you know
we go into some of the wisdom behind you
know uh his akhlaq just the way he lives
the example he leads um why is there
this this giant
you know preconceived notion this taboo
whenever people think about him
obviously as muslims and he it goes back
all of it goes back to the shoe hitting
in the face
and the issue of hitting in the face
being haram him being something
doing some haram like i said people want
to x him out other people obviously now
but he's become a role model for the
people because
he came at a time where you know
islam any or the muslims would say has
become very weak islam
is never weak but the muslims have
become very weak
the muslims don't respect themselves the
muslims don't honor themselves
so here came a man from the mountains of
dagestan you know
and he was a very simple man who came in
and
revived many of these principles in in
the life of the muslims
and he taught you know that's one of the
great things he taught
the muslims that you can excel in
something because islam wants us
to excel this is one of the teachings of
islam
that all loves when you do something
that you perfected and obviously this
year is he the goat or not
i might differ here you know with this i
might take i might take jon jones when
it comes to being the goat but none of
that i mean
he's definitely any any one of one of
the greatest of all times
and no doubt about that but then so you
see he perfected what he does
and he perfected it but it didn't change
him also one of the teachings of islam
also one of the ways of of the salaf of
the pious predecessors the early
any you know members of this ummah from
the sahaba and the early generation of
the muslim
where they could be somebody who was
very rich but also one who was very
devoted to the deen
look for example abu bakr al-sadiq was
very rich
was very rich big businessman at the
same time uh even more rich with them
was
all three of them were from the rich
sahaba from the big businessmen of the
sabbath
all three of them were from the ten who
were promised paradise by the prophet
salallahu
the combination between the deen and the
dunya is the reality of the muslim
they're all of them also very simple
they were not attached to the dunya
they used this money as a tool to
benefit themselves
in this life to be able to plant for the
this is what the the true muslim does
and even i was i was very happy when
when khabib started becoming more
successful he started with several
charity projects and
and africa and things like that that's
what someone is supposed to do when
allah you know bless him with with
wealth
and with fame but the really thing that
really you know is and from the benefits
that really kind of you know
what sticked out to me when i i did this
about 54 things with benefit
is the issue of you know the honor
and not being shy not compromising
and he's in and we talked about this
before as well about the
the muslims who are too shy to practice
their faith the ones who are always
always want to compromise and
and and do things that are haram in
order to please other people and you
look now for just
the clip that went you know went around
recently about him not shaking hands
we've seen it several times
he doesn't shake hands and not
compromising this is what our religion
teaches we don't shake hands with
opposite gender
not not compromising when when when the
the lady in in riyadh
of all places i you know asked him about
um you know
then how how a woman can be successful
as a fighter
and what did he say to her you know to
be to be a fighter in your house
didn't compromise this is his belief
system that this is where the woman
should be focusing is on her house and
her family he's not going to say now
because i'm successful in this
and the right thing to say as an as an
enemy championship
is how you can do it as a woman is to do
this and this and this and to do this
and this and to train like this and
he didn't he didn't compromise he said
right away that you know
you should fight in your house that's
when you should fight this is where you
should be raising the children
the societies have been corrupted why
because the women are not with their
children and in their houses they're out
with it with
chasing their careers and the houses are
being destroyed and even muslim
households as well as they're following
in the footsteps so he didn't compromise
in several examples
i remember and the khutbah mentioned
some things uh you know he always made
it clear that his faith came first
ufc 200 which at that time was the
biggest ever you know this was the
biggest event
it was in ramadan he was like no i'm not
taking part in it he was very clear
wasn't willing to compromise even though
he needed that stepping stone in his
career during that time as one of the
biggest stepping stones for him
would have been usc 200 but he refused
to take part because
it was in ramadan and he also did any
even like something small
to us maybe when the the
reporter said and he had said to him and
whiskey like in the same sentence
and he stopped them and he said don't
don't say those two together
even though any would we say that
something and the reporter didn't mean
anything negative by it right
but he said just don't mix those two
words together okay he was always in a
sudden
he's not shy to explain how he believes
and always you know attaching
it to to allah subhanahu wa ta'ala you
know it says it's allah you know
and it's saying alhamdulillah and how
many people around the world now from
the non-muslims
they know the word alhamdulillah they
know the meaning of it
and how he spread that word through
throughout the world it's something
somebody that we say
as muslims we should say a minimum of
175 times a day
as if just at the salat and al-qaeda say
after the salah we're going to say
throughout the day if we do other pray a
bit more we're going to say
say it more than that and then what does
that mean alhamdulillah why are they
saying alhamdulillah
even one of the beautiful things about
khabib and
i don't want to you know you guys asked
me to talk about it and eddie recently
on the dean show asked me to talk about
the show of conor mcgregor
you know i didn't want to you know
always talk too much about it i don't
want to become like you know
uh the mma guy who's always talking
about these type of issues
and we have some of our youth who
constantly talk about these issues as
well so i said
there's there are people out here we're
talking about which i think is good i
think it's positive
but obviously there's a lot we can
reflect and gain on it and honestly and
i do mention it
even his stance against uh macron in the
french
what was happening in france against our
prophet beautiful stance
you know once again not compromising
strong
beautiful words from someone who is now
as a kudua who is it was a role model
who's
someone who people people follow and
look up to he came and he
he showed the muslims how they should be
not like you know you know
shying off or certain governments
strengthening their relations with
france during this time subhanallah them
if the people had a stance and this is
the thing if we don't have stances we
don't have people
willing to take stances we're never
going to progress as an ummah i talked
about this the other day
i know it offended some people and i
talked about the issue of the the gcc
countries
taking a stance against sri lanka when
they want to ban the
the niqab there the same thing when
france bent the nikop
i mean who who what was the best
government response to france when the
nikab issue
was directly from the white house
if we could get that clip it was it was
really really good what the guy said he
was a spokesman for the white house it
was during the the
obama administration he said that we are
against this
he said we believe it's a woman's right
if she wants to cover her face even what
trump said actually was amazing about
the nikhil it was really really good
what he said about the nikon honestly
and but we're the muslim rulers who are
saying this or taking these stances
and he said they said that obviously
we're still allies with france but we
don't we don't agree with this at least
any where's the muslims who stood up
against this if muslims did
any and the the crazy thing is is that
it's the
it's the fatwas from your scholars
in these countries who the sisters took
from in order to say that it's far for
the woman
to cover her face obviously before that
you have there and many of the other
methamps as well
um but i'm some of the the contemporary
scholars anyways
that you know it's from these countries
so any where's the stance against them
if on a higher level and people who took
take stances um i'm i'm bad with some of
these footballers names
the soccer guy what's his name uh the
turkish brother who took the stance
plays for arsenal um i forget his name
you guys don't probably don't watch
uh soccer anyways in in north america so
you don't know what i'm talking about
but
he had a very good he had a very good a
good good stance as well
when these people speak out you know and
and they have stances
it's going to have an impact
alhamdulillah so he's done that as well
and showing us as muslims how we should
be to be proud of religion
and to stand up for our religion you
know you see him with his worship
he is constantly making dua to allah
you see him when he's in the dojo
praying his training didn't stop him
from from getting up to pray you see
when he's he's chilling out hanging out
with his friends you see him with his
little
you know his uh the the the though that
they were
in the house a lot of times and in arab
countries you see he has a stove on
hanging out
with the with his with his brothers and
he's praying and
you know he leads them a lot of times in
the prayer mashallah and so you see this
is this what you need to
this how the muslim needs to be i
remember
uh in ireland we went on a
with a group of the youth who went to uh
the beach
the first day we went we played football
or they played football anyways
um soccer meeting uh on the beach when
it came time to play mogrip
it was a great opportunity for us now to
make wudu from
the sea water from the using there which
is it's a bit salty when you make the
odor but
it is permissible to make it from from
from the sea waters the prophet isaiah
taught us so how many we made we made
wudu and we prayed
the next day we went to another part of
the beach on the other side and they
were swimming and having fun and what
have you
and it came time for salah
so alhamdulillah we got up and we prayed
we prayed salat
in front of everybody it was you know
and you know in ireland when it's a
summer day
you know you have a lot of people out
there because they don't get much sun
there
so the people that we prayed right in
front of them a brother asked me to give
a short talk
and i said you know what i said there's
no need i said what we gained today with
them
i mean he forced me at the end to give a
small talk which i talked about this a
lot anyways but i talk about the same
thing i'm saying to you now that
what we gained from that we didn't need
and to do anything else
with the youth the fact that we had the
the honor
to fulfill our duty as muslims which is
to get up and to pray
that alhamdulillah it's it's going to
show the people and people like people
respect
people respect you and i i talked to you
guys about this before when you respect
yourself and your respect to reason
it increases the respect for the people
in their hearts for you
even if they don't like what you're
doing even if they disagree even if
something if they hate what you're doing
you'll still find that they they have a
form of respect for you subhanallah
and i'll tell you a story that happened
to us in ireland we went with the
youth once again we went to hiking
and there's apparently you can see also
on the picture that had some amazing
amazing places you hike up in the
mountains
also you come out with you know mountain
is this big lake in the middle there
it's absolutely
stunning so as we were there
um it came time for salat once again
it's very cold
but to make although in the cold water
we did it um
our hanover brothers who had to wash
their feet were a bit uh
had a bit more difficulty than us who
who wiped on their socks obviously
we made our uldu in the cold water and
as we were preparing for the salat a
group of people came
to the same area we were sitting in um
it was like 11 women and one dude you
know i was like this guy
he's one guy with all of these women
masha'allah
or michelle i don't know but uh anyways
not a muslim guy and he's
he's come up with all these women you
know so as he comes up
and he uh they sit down they start to
talk the youth start to get a bit shy
and i can't feel it
i'm like who's going to call the other
one
everyone's looking for anyone else i
know we're we're in the middle of this
night we're calling
i'm not and i'm not going to be shy
because these non-muslims
wrote up on us now i'm not going to call
the event so
you know what i i'm going to be the i'm
going to be the example i'm going to get
up
you know bismillah i got up and allahu
akbar echo in this
you know we're down in like this this
cannon with the lake in the mountains
it's beautiful you know
and i hear the people talking i can't
hear what they're saying because i'm
making it into that
so i thought they were saying something
negative you know they're women and
stuff like that but i'm getting offended
you know
and i don't know if i hear the dude
talking like this guy better not be
talking about you know he
better hope he's not saying anything you
know i started to get a bit offended you
know
but when i finished what i realized is
that
they were talking and the other ones
were telling them
be quiet have respect this is their call
for prayer
look at this so they were quieting the
other ones so they they wouldn't be any
noise
you know i mean it's not really an issue
for them to talk any
during that time but and out of respect
look at that you know
i respected myself respected my call for
prayer my time for prayer
they respected it as well alhamdulillah
and even when we started to pray then
they
ended up just just going and we went to
hiking another area of the mountain
subhanallah
so it was any it was it was a any
a learning experience but that type of
respect when you have it
one like people respect you and i see
this time and time again
where people have stances and they hold
affirms to the values that people
respect you and this is one of the
things
that khabib and has done and even now
the message he sent i i totally disagree
with what he did
after the mcgregor fight um
it turned out to be pretty good in the
end to balance with you
i didn't think it would turn out that
good honestly i thought it was gonna be
much more ugly for him and
and and for his legacy but i don't think
it's done anything to it honestly i mean
in some ways i think actually could have
helped him
but i i would have much preferred you
know the uh and because he
he mauled the guy you know even the fact
he lost round three
if you know anything about mma it did
look like he lost round three
but when you go back and you see that
mcgregor wasn't hitting him
he was moving back he was more mcgregor
was throwing hits it looked like he was
connecting
but he was missing so his punches
weren't accurate and khabib was actually
hitting him more
so in reality he's still undefeated um
uh like what's the joke now what's this
guy uh
uh where's he where's he from is he is
he uh
paulo costo or he's brazilian okay i
thought he might be puerto rican
he's uh i don't know what you're about
to say yeah yeah i thought your boy yeah
he's always i say i'm still undefeated
sober huh it's like
the guy he can't admit that he lost it
look your wounds and move on man
yeah yeah it's like it's like the
craziest thing i've heard that's like
what is this guy talking about right
subhanallah so any and in reality and
you look at khabib is still undefeated
never never lost any rounds honestly
because he didn't lose that realm so he
totally he totally mauled the guy
but if you know mma you know
respect for conor and for his coaches
for that fight in his last fight
um with pourier no no he that was bad
coaching
he wasn't ready for the everybody's
doing late kicks man there's you've got
to be ready for the late kicks
but he was ready for khabib his his
defense on the ground was absolutely in
a
textbook the way he moved his hips the
way he got up was khabib
is just like they say a different animal
i don't know someone call her brother
that but
he said he's a he's a beast once he gets
on top he's like a snake you just can't
just like devours you you can't get away
from him you know and people
and everyone who fought him said you
realize that after he's on you
but if you look at conor's movement when
he was on the ground he when he he was
doing everything properly
and he what you're supposed to do when
you get caught in that situation he was
well trained he was well prepared
even his jitsu coach who khabib had the
issue with he trained him properly you
might like the guy
but he he trained him properly he was
ready and if you you go back and you and
you you study the tape and you look at
it
he was moving really really good a lot
of muslims even some of our brothers who
train like oh he's completely didn't do
anything no
he did what he's supposed to do but
khabib was just at an
at a total another level that's why he
wasn't able
uh you know to do anything the point is
is that
after he mauled him for for four rounds
that was enough
if he had if he had stayed the same
humble way in this
and i think that would have been much
better for him and for his legacy but
you know
like you know shaytan gets the best of
all this and that's also actually a
lesson
actually any if you look at that i
didn't think about that in that
sense but now if you think about it
because i always told i'd like to
reflect that's why i have
54 or 56 points that i mentioned the
things we can benefit we can make this
number 57 now
after that that the fact that you know i
actually i might have mentioned that
actually in the points i don't remember
but the fact is that he made a mistake
and he admitted it and this i didn't
mention yeah
but also and that's a lesson for all of
us
is that yes we might make mistakes yes
shaytan might get the best of us
it happens to all of us and he i
mentioned i remember one of the
the the shaykh says i like that you know
uh it's always an expression that i use
i have a video
recently i did about it where i say that
there's no floyd money mayweathers
and your battle will shape on you're not
going to go 50 or no there's no
no khabib's we're going to go 29 no you
are going to lose
shaytan he's going to knock you out he's
going to get you sometimes
on a split decision sometimes he's going
to get you on in anderson's he's going
to beat you you're going to fall
this is from the hadith of the prophet
salallahu that all of the children of
adam are
that they make mistakes and then he said
the best of those who make mistakes
though are the
ones who are constantly repenting so
it's not about not
falling it's about what you do when you
do fall so once we fall that we bounce
back
and that we reflect on we we reflect on
our mistakes
to become better people just just as the
fighter
reflects on his uh you know what i did
right and what i did wrong
in order to to improve and to become
and to become better in the future
there's a muslim the same thing we go
back to the drawing board
we go back to the to the to the to the
tape
watch tape so what did we do wrong huh
what did we do wrong how did shaytan get
what were the things
that got me and something very
interesting with this i don't know i've
ever
ever i mean i think i shared it once
before um
i was doing some counseling with a
brother and
practicing brother brother involved in
dua and in dawa
um every now and then
shaytan will get the best of him he will
fall into watching some uh
things he shouldn't be watching that he
had opened up to somebody open up to me
and i spoke with him
um and his name is that was it's not a
start to expose our brothers exposes we
don't expose the sins of others
alhamdulillah
and he when he and it reflected we
looked in
what's getting you he found that
sometimes
you know maybe he'll watch some things
on youtube which are halal to watch
something would come up for example
watching a prank prank show
all of a sudden some women come up in
bikinis
you're a dude what's that going to do to
you boom trigger something
you know now and and indirectly not
right away it wouldn't he wouldn't go in
but
that triggered something you know what
at the gym
when he would be training at the gym uh
you know
non-muslim country people listen to
music out loud and in a lot of the gyms
that he found that um
he would listen to the music maybe a bit
more than he should have you know kind
of get into it you know
especially someone who has a ja helia
you know you hear some stuff man you
know especially the stuff you used to
listen to back in the day
you know i remember like like back in
the day when we used to
you know tupac and and dr dre stoop dog
in the chronic when it first came out
if i hear some stuff like that now man
it's just gonna be like that's it
we can benefit from technology but if
you hear something like that you know
it can have an impact on you so this is
very important
you know that we we we study to see
how do we fall how can we become better
subhanallah so
he realized that these small things that
he was being easy going on
watching certain things that it led him
to you know look at that which was
uh i mentioned for example the ufc girls
he said
i wouldn't you know sometimes i wouldn't
lower my gaze so those small things
would trigger
to take the next step and watch
something and obviously he would make
toba and wouldn't do it for like another
couple
you know weeks or months or whatever it
was alhamdulillah but every now and then
again just it got it got from the fact
that he would
fall back into it so he we want to open
up to someone alhamdulillah
we're able to solve the problem so
that's a lot of times you have to you
have to do studies
and look into how you fell into it what
to do about it
so obviously with him you know making
that mistake and
i feel it's going to make him a better
person and it's also a very valuable
lesson for all of us
you know that what shaytan if we let
shaytan get us he let's shake
on get it but also he bounced back he
bounced back quick from it
i think a lot had to do any with fear of
his father in the beginning as he
mentioned in an interview
may allah have mercy upon his father
subhanallah so you're the
the the respect and that's also one of
the lessons man just a great lesson
for our youth today when it comes to
you know respecting your mother and your
father we know the status
that islam gives to them but
you know where are we when it comes to
that honestly all of us especially the
youth
nowadays you know the ones who grow up
in the west especially even farther away
because the society
is so ant anti-family you know it's just
not it doesn't have family values
anymore
but you see you know khabib just his
father how emotional he was and the
impact he had on his life
the respect he had from the fear he had
for him when he made that when he jumped
over that cage
he said the thing is about going back
home now it's not the ufc who scares me
it's not losing 500 000
in a fight instead of going home to face
his dead
this is what this would the the fear
that he had of his dad
when he was on the top of the world 2090
his father's dreams were 30 no
when his mother said this is the last
one look at the respect
right there this is i mean the amazing
lesson that's not in the
bible because it happened later i mean
they show his father i believe it's in
there
but he took it to another level with his
mother subhanallah
that's just an amazing lesson i mean we
can go on and on and above the things
that you can benefit
and that and that's why i said from the
beginning of the question look
issue of hitting in the face between him
and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
you know some of the some of the
brothers who who i'm uh i'm friends with
on facebook
or you know professional fighters and
this you know
that's between them and allah you know
but they're my brothers and i i like the
brothers
who have that that you know that that is
the honor that they're proud to be
muslims
you know the the they make it clear that
yes i'm a fighter but i'm a muslim i
think that's that's beautiful
we should support them for that aspect
not supporting if they're doing
something
like i said between him and allah i'm
not going to come because i like mma
because
i like you know this guy oh it's it's
not that haram brother mashallah you
know
that's not that's not my approach i said
what you're doing is not correct
but the other aspects you're doing i
have to applaud you for that
and you're you're my brother and i'm
going to stand by you and because of
that
uh one second bro before we continue uh
you're gonna be able to cut it out when
you're when you're editing right
my charger which i had took
to plug in before i forgot now my
battery is about to die
no it's take your time
you saw that he was in his underwear bro
we're gonna keep it
[Laughter]
the bengali brothers in the somali
brothers have a dress man
it is it's called the punjabi
they call it lunging
that's hilarious yeah yeah and
even again it said this to the work and
in the gulf countries they were where
they
are like this one on the bottom but they
were the throb on top of it
let me see bring one leg up bring one
leg up real quick
no no they put a leg up man
[Music]
yeah because obviously underneath
there's nothing underneath that's that's
that's the problem
[Laughter]
there's actually a funny story because
in some gulf countries
uh and oman and the emirates that's all
they wear under their thoughts
qatar to an extent they they wear both
of them um
kuwait and certainly they were the
they're like the regular like white uh
white pants under the though um bahrain
i'm not sure if they both i don't know i
don't know what their customers
emiratis they were nothing but this i
always have it was when i used to live
in emirates
um that's all they were under the phobes
so there was
there was a soccer match and they got
into a fight afterwards so there it was
actually the things
so the guy runs out and he's like
they're fighting the other team their
team lost everybody's upset
so the guy does this big kick to the
other guy obviously underneath there's
nothing on
so everything's exposed under as he's
jumping so they actually brought it on
the news
but they cover up his like his private
part when he did it
he's like i'm up on top on the bottom
you know he's he's wide open
spread out
you can't fight with something like that
that's that is that that might be good
it's very comfortable that's the thing i
want to have in the house is very
comfortable that's all i wear in the
house
so that's when i'm filming i just uh i
put this on i leave that but if you go
to yemen
uh and that's that's how they were they
were taught like a shirt like this
and then about also in somalia it's very
famous they dress like that as well
although isn't isn't it called in india
doti
they call it i know that i don't do that
i'm from
i'm from bangladesh i used to grow up
seeing my grandfather with that
it's it's called donkey so if you if you
guys made it this far type in this yeah
monkey
ventilation i think in india it's called
the uh a doti
is like they're like white pants but
then they're like
you're basically nothing underneath no
no no no this is not
the lumia is actually it's a wrap it's
just like it's like a piece of cloth big
piece of club
and they wrap it around them so it's
like like a towel almost you know like a
long skirt
this is yeah yeah so they wrap it around
themselves
it's it's very comfortable and once you
get used to it you know it's just uh
very very nice that's why that's why and
the house that's all i wear you know in
the house
and i used to wear it i live in the
emirates outside as well um
under the thumb you should wear it when
you're rolling with someone
big trouble then huh get you get you get
you in the in the
in the scissors and then what do you
call it the triangle choke man
oh no no you're not gonna catch me in
there
i have so many thoughts that i had going
on during that amazing uh
those amazing points masha'allah um i
don't know i i
feel like nowadays with like political
correctness and cancer culture and that
stuff we've we've adopted these you know
mentalities that that tell us to just
you know cancel people
if there's something we don't like in
the slightest from them throughout the
whole person right
a lot of the time you you hear women say
like things like throw throw out the
whole man
right as like this this insulting uh
a statement subhanallah but when it
comes to someone like javi like
imagine how much good he's done like
even my brother right even my brother
he he you know he came back and started
praying and stuff
after watching habib fight and he was
devastated
when habib retired he was like
devastated subhanallah
and to see my brother come and and ask
me you know if he can pray with me
and all that because of habib how are
you gonna how are you gonna come to me
and say that habib is not a good role
model don't look up them and
i'm gonna put you in a triangle hold
soon yeah
that's it and oh that's always i always
say you know from the beginning the
khutbah said
look objectively you know what can we
benefit there's so many i mean i
mentioned
54 and he then added two things and then
56 and now with
some of our new things 5750 i don't know
where we are now but michelle
there's a lot of things you know that
you can benefit that's how we have to be
as believers is to look at the positive
i even remember remember maybe you guys
saw the clip and i remember one of the
them he contacted me and he praised me
for
what i said about our brother muhammad
salah
you know who when he took the picture
next to the christmas christmas tree
yeah
yeah so i mean i i said a very uh mary
any mostly
christmas that was the title but when
when you go inside the video i said look
what i said this is the same guy that
all everyone was praising and
you know putting the you know his
picture when he's reading the quran and
when he's
making dua everyone's you know
everyone's praising him he messed up now
and now it's just like
the the the the the knives are falling
on the poor guy right
i said he made a mistake you know cover
up for your brother you know don't
and and and then as it came in the
hadith the prophet says tell him
don't you know let shaytan and he don't
don't support shaytan against your
brother right
and he's in in in if if the muslims were
always to turn against khabib
who's he going to have any he has allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
but he's going to have all of the the
the the non-muslims who what what are
they calling to they call them to good
he's our brother you know he made a
mistake in one aspect what about all the
other good that he has
and this we have to look at any muslims
even the brother who's with us in our
islamic center and local community
he has a mistake but look at the good
he's doing even i mentioned in one of my
lectures last night and you might find
someone
and who's has a lot of bad things
but he does something good for islam and
he has to be applauded for that you know
even like some of the words like dave
chappelle said he and
the interview had recently and he said i
said i'm a muslim but i'm not a good one
you know
he was honest obviously but any he has
some good things he said
even there was an interview where they
did with um uh
akon i saw this obviously on the dean
show and he did it with uh with brother
gabriel
when he and he talked about polygamy
brilliant brilliant what he talked about
you know
obviously he has some you know very bad
songs and some you know
some things as muslims that we don't
accept but i'm the you know he he's
basically i'm a muslim
it's part of my faith this is how we do
with this i mean i
i mean i really like you know a lot of
the things that that he said
so we can we can benefit from this we
have to applaud that do we cancel him
all together
at the same time you have other
individuals who might be someone because
he is a
celebrity who has more bad than good but
the fact he's muslim just because his
celebrities
will bring him to propagate our
organization or to do this and that
we have to that that's that's that's a
red line there but if we have a brother
who's you know
generally good and he and any what he
has is good but he has a mistake here
that
this is our brother and we we benefited
from him and shantana and we can advise
him
uh we can advise him as well for uh you
know
for the mistakes that he has that's how
we need to be as a muslim we need to be
and it looks like the brother says
how brilliant is that i mean and how
many stories if we were to you know
ask people they're gonna people who
started praying off it's not the first
time i've heard that
people came back to islam and practiced
that because of khabib in a time of
darkness
and he was in he he gave a bit of light
to the to the believers you know
you can excel at something and you can
still be devoted to your religion at the
same time
you don't have to compromise you don't
have to do any uh
any uh other forms of haram you know
alhamdulillah and this is something you
know very very any
there are other athletes who have done
it by the way but
any when you have that type of isn't
that type of honor and
it just the the the the the that you can
spread you know
throughout the ummah it's it's amazing
may allah bless him and increase
subhanallah
i'm like a loss right now don't don't
turn to me bro i have my i have my mic
muted because usually i'm just like
going from one point to another
uh coordinating it but dog my my cat
is right outside my door she's meowing
crazy so i don't even want to unmute it
because it might get into you know
interfere with value
but yeah just just just off the rip like
i'm gonna link
the the video that you made the futpa
where you go into all those wonderful
points that our brother habib did and
continues to do
and the way he lives but just
in summation a couple points that you
know you really want to share with us in
this podcast
even though i will link it down in the
description box of this episode
what would they be some main takeaways
from
i think the main thing we mentioned in
the beginning just the issue of
of of being proud to be a muslim
and not compromising and i think that's
that's one of the main takeaways
the issue of the family of of being
devoted to your to your salat
um even i mentioned recently about that
about big romney
bodybuilding is is it bodybuilding and i
i put it right there i said look
i said i'm not going to you know talk
about this
the bodybuilding itself is but the
posing they do in those shorts
that's going to make it haram obviously
that that aspect of it once again
not all aspects of it are haram but look
at the brother
and in the minute video he's praying
alhamdulillah
as somebody who was at that success mr
olympia that means he's number one in
the world
numero uno number one the top but yet
he's still he's still praying look
before the olympia i mean i i
i looked at his page on facebook
all of it has to talk about allah and in
his post
so make him do it so this is something
to be applauded man
and how many people would reach that
level they would go astray we sit back
now
on our couches and we talk oh man okay
if you were three cent level of success
and you had that much money and that
much fitna in front of you
you think you would be devoted you you
might say it now
but the reality if you had all those
women
and you say man no no i would i would i
wouldn't be involved you know with
something like that
you have the women throwing themselves
at you man you can have all the women
you want with that success and that
money and that fame
but yet someone stays devoted to his
wife and and fears the law subhanahu
watana
is that not to be applauded and so these
the this is any
the the lessons then here that these
brothers they teach you can excel at the
at your sport at your craft you can be
at the top of the world because he's at
the top of the mma world
and even considered by many to be the
goat but yet someone who's still devoted
someone who still has honor
someone who still doesn't compromise
when the lady comes to him
he doesn't shake hands with the opposite
jetter gender because this is the
teachings of islam alhamdulillah
and when you see how he is with his
parents number one
when it came time we said ufc 200
religions first
ramadan he's still training but he
trains less it's it's time to fast
and you you you the issue with his
mother i think that was just
amazing amazing amazing wow and if that
didn't bring tears to your eyes
subhanallah
as a muslim why he retired because my
mother said this is the last one allahu
akbar
our our young brothers and sisters who
are listening
and even though even us as older
brothers you know and where
where are we from our parents if they
told us not to do it subhanallah
you know i mean one of the things that
had an impact on me
uh my wife she's still upset with me
about cutting my hair
uh i just saw a picture yesterday when i
was training it was actually almost done
half of my back smile
my father didn't like it you know and i
explained i said the fact that i'm not
living next to my father
um that kind of makes me you know
i don't know i should be rebellious but
i mean i just i didn't cut it as quick
as i did because
he requested that i cut my hair right
but that's one of the
that's one of the factors when i did cut
my hair
was because he wasn't happy with it with
the long hair
you know out of respect for him and even
if you know like you might have saw my
picture on my instagram
that's his that's the picture is fast
for actually for him i'll put that one
okay
so i just got my hair cut look good with
my sweater on because
i went this in the show him and you had
something you had requested
so i did that for you actually it was
horrible training with by the way i
don't want training with the long hair
that wasn't uh that wasn't that wasn't
fun i'll tell you that much always
coming down to your face
and sticking to yours you're sweating
there was a hamdulillah so this type of
type of lesson these tablets i think
these these are the main things but i
mean there's many other things in his
his relationship with you know with the
non-muslims and
building ties building relationships
that's that's some of the best form of
dawah
you know we talked about you know giving
out muslims it's any
it's not always about you know me giving
you a book or teaching you something
about islam
it can just be that that relationship
that that bridge building and look how
many of the non-muslims they actually
love him now too
the relationships he has with his
teammates like you know dc and others
where they're they're very strong and
the relationship they have uh
relationship we have even with some
officials some government and even
though people might not agree with that
but obviously he has his outlook um of
having those relations and
and the benefits that that can have as
well so there's many many
you know benefits that you could have
and even i think you know individuals
like him
have removed a lot of the hatred towards
you know
the non-muslims had and a lot of the
racism that
non-muslims had even a lot of the double
standards that the west had towards
islam and the muslims a lot of it has
been removed
even something very very interesting i
mean from the
positive outcomes of his fight in in
with conor mcgregor is that
many of the the non-muslims
no longer look at what france now
keeps saying is freedom of speech you
know what's in the obviously freedom of
speech
when it's not insulting others it's not
degrading others
your right to have your opinion and then
you look at the double standards
if you were to look at certain movements
or idealities or lifestyles
in a western society now if we're to
speak about that
that's not allowed that's hate speech
and that's this and you're the
but when it comes to um muslims
it's open game right but i think a lot
of them understood from this
you know that you just don't do that you
don't talk about a man's religion
you have respect for a man's belief and
and a lot of
that his stance and his anger
and you know what happened with conor i
think a lot of people would change you
know so he
even conor himself and he we should be
thankful for him
stuff for lying everybody says something
a how could you be thankful right
but his thing about you know talking
about
about the religion of khabib it actually
had a positive impact in the
alhamdulillah we have to look look for
the positive in things
i'm not saying you know it was good
thing that he did obviously we don't
accept it but
nonetheless and in many of the
non-muslims now they're gonna you know
they think twice before they say
something negative about islam and the
muslims not out of fear
now they're gonna we're gonna jump out
of the cage on them or something like
that and do the eagle
and jump on a like he did no it's not
that's not the reason but because they
just
it's not right and it's it's it's not
fair to have those doubles and it's not
correct
and the people understood it now from
this alhamdulillah
and subhanallah i say we
we made some good points that uh
i'm trying to gather my thoughts on just
the last part that you were saying
because
so many people today are just ashamed of
that we talked about in the beginning we
talked about it in the middle
we're wrapping it up right now that feel
unapologetically a muslim
right now i'm not saying you know just
be all up in the face about it
but it's like there's a difference
between you know being a coward and just
not sharing everything and putting it
out there right i'm not saying you have
to
not everyone you know everyone should
give dawah right the prophet
said even if one verse one i have from
the quran you can share that
but i'm not saying everyone has to go do
that now but don't
shy away from it don't put up this wall
between you as a muslim
and try to become like the disbelievers
right because that was also said that
there's going to come a day where you
know we as an ummah we just become
so similar to the disbelievers it's
astounding i think that day is not too
far
well i think a lot of it actually
unfortunately is in front of us
i don't know romney you got any thoughts
before we wrap it up
uh it looks like romney doesn't have any
thoughts um
i say we wrap it up man brother looks
like he's tired
of course we have to get some sleep uh
what time is it it's um
1 15 1 139 yeah i have a lecture in a
couple of hours in
california as well so yeah let's let him
get some rest
catching that man sheik abdul raheem
thank you so much for
filming these two episodes with us
you're a very busy guy but inshallah
this this reaches a lot of a lot of
hearts a lot of souls because
at the end of the day yes we get a
little too caught up and this is this is
for people like us
people that are you know trying to
promote islam and spread the deen and
spread truth
and then reality of what things are
we get a little too caught up sometimes
on you know
a message to disbelievers or not you
know non-muslims
you know and and try to convince them
with a song but it's like
our home base we we forget it sometimes
and we lose sight of what
it is and i get it because the perfect
example of this is
you have non-muslim countries like
america and uh
canada so basically north america
we all these countries we we classify
what's going on in china's genocide
but when you look at what's happening in
muslim countries oh no
you know don't speak about that right
saudi arabia you know all these
countries that they have these these
trades and
you know relations with you know ccp and
they can't have to maintain that
and they're they're afraid of speaking
out on it is it right no you know
are they kind of being empowered about
it of course for dunya reasons too which
which
which is the most pathetic thing but at
the end of the day it really goes
actually i believe there's a lot of
benefit in that because i think that
many of the westerners
uh you know the especially ones who have
strong intellect
and even the ones who are you know might
not be the the strongest in the
intellect but
it just become so blatantly clear that
the issue of
democracy and and freedom and all this
that it's it's it's not real and it it's
not what they've been saying to be in
the double standards
they've seen so much of it you know and
they're starting to realize that hey
what we've
what we've been saying and the the these
slogans that we were raised on
you know freedom for all and justice for
all and all this
it's really just a lot of calamities
it's just you know it's just hearsay
it's not it's not a reality
and it's only a reality when there's a
benefit i mean if china was
you know uh was on the same page as
america if they weren't someone who was
you know competing with america
if they weren't you know um uh that you
you wouldn't you wouldn't find it
wouldn't be a genocide this would be
this would be the sad truth
you know there would be a reason for
this
and or if they were to say this you know
there's just like they said with the
other countries
you mentioned because they were very
blatant with it it goes back to business
there's business that we have you know
and the sad thing is is that
even the issue of like the war on terror
which is not really something
you know mainstream alhamdulillah it's
not really an issue anymore i mean i'm
sure it still is but not
like it was in ahmedabad so the blessing
of allah but the the point is that
even this you know obviously there were
allies with
you know the the the sort of other
countries
that was one of their the key things so
he said we need we need to stay together
because that
they're not even mentioning that a lot
really it's just you know more of like
the trade and other other things that
you said during your issues
they're focusing on now so it's more
like even blatant now that that that's
the reason why
you know we we keep the ties and things
like that so
it's just it's a sad situation but i
think it's it's showing the the reality
and the truth of so many people so there
could be a lot of good coming from that
you know so always we have to look for
the good
and really positive inshallah
one time once again huge shout out to
sheikh abdullahi mccarthy if you have
made it this far
type in hashtag be you
until next time i'm so shocked that you
held the floor you know
that eloquently masha allah for that
long at you know 1 15 in the morning so
may allah bless you immensely happy and
allow us to be leaders for the righteous
habit i learned so much from this one
talk unfortunately i missed the first
ball go back and watch insha allah
may allah bless everybody who washed
into this point uh and allow us to be
you know good muslim men and women and
be proud of our deen
with that being said
to them
message it um after friday prayers and
i was with a friend in the car and he
was like really happy about hadith that
the the sheikh and the sermon mentioned
and um
he said he said something interesting so
the brother was really happy about it he
was like
yeah you know this hadith you know it
says this is this
i was so into it and i was like you know
bro um
how do you even know that's authentic
and he was like man the shirt said
you know the message you know you think
the imam
giving the sermon is gonna quote
something that's inauthentic
so i went back home and or to the dorms
i checked it out
and indeed it was inauthentic and
that kind of messed me up because i
became a lot more skeptical than i was
um and that's how my journey started
[Music]
um